[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
sur france 3 bourgogne
ils ne sont pas du genre à hausser le
ton mais cette fois ci les retraités ont
décidé de se mobiliser ils ont manifesté
vous le savez la semaine dernière dans
toute la france ni assisté ni
privilégiée disaient les slogans de ces
seniors qui ont bien du mal à
l'encaisser l'idée d'être classé dans la
catégorie nantis ou privilégier la
hausse de la csg de 1,7 point pourtant
annoncé lors de la campagne des manuels
macron ne passe pas alors est-ce une
bataille de nantis les retraités sont
ils les oubliés des réformes d'emmanuel
macron au delà de leur pouvoir d'achat
la question de la place de nos aînés
dans la société est posée doit-on parler
de conflits de générations on en débat
ce matin avec mes invités michel dago
mais bonjour bonjour vous êtes membre du
bureau national de l'ump est racée
l'union nationale des retraités et des
personnes âgées qui appelait notamment à
manifester la semaine dernière michel
dago mais vous êtes aussi dit koné je le
précise
en quelques mots qu'est ce qui ne va pas
cette hausse de 1,7 point de la cg sans
aucune compensation parce que elle est
applicable aussi aux actifs et on ne
veut pas s'opposer nous aux actifs
enfin bon cette compensation des actifs
allez quand même très minime j'ai omis
un exemple on ne peut être que tu es tu
vois là mais elle n'existe pas selon
vous pour les retraités
non non on va y revenir dans un instant
rémy rebeyrotte bonjour je vous êtes
député la république en marche de
saône-et-loire alors qu'est ce que vous
répondez en deux mots aussi puis on y
reviendra plus largement à aux
inquiétudes des retraités alors d'abord
c'est pas la première fois qu'il ya une
hausse de la csg dans notre pays vous
rappeler qu'elle a été instituée en 1991
cette cg pour faire en sorte que pour
équilibrer notre système social
nos régimes sociaux nos différents
régimes sociaux il puisse y avoir un
appel non seulement aux salariés et aux
actifs mais aussi effectivement aux
personnes retraitées et puis aux revenus
du patrimoine nouveaux revenus du
capital c'est ça
en fait la csg donc c'est une
augmentation effectivement de la csg
j'observe que beaucoup d des retraités
d'aujourd'hui étaient des actifs de 1991
j'en étais aussi jeunes actifs
évidemment je me suis pas plaint quant à
l'époque pour équilibrer les régimes
sociaux parlait du retour du trou la
sécurité sociale à l'époque je me suis
pas plaint quand on a mis aussi des
retraités à contribution et les revenus
du patrimoine
parce que en élargissant l'assiette on a
fait en sorte mais à l'époque on parlait
pas de travailleurs pauvres
on a fait en sorte on y reviendra mais
de ne pas mettre tout le poids sur les
actifs et sur le train sur le travail
alors on va y venir bien sûr je rappelle
simplement que vous qui vous nous
regardez vous pouvez bien sûr réagir en
direct à cette émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag dit mme paul
bourgogne rémy rebeyrotte
est-ce qu'il n'y en a pas qui paye un
petit peu plus quand même que les autres
dans cette histoire alors dans cette
histoire s'ils voulaient d'abord il y a
pas mal d'éléments de compensation je
m'explique sur des retraités qui sont
concernés globalement dans cette réforme
pour simplement les retraités parce que
nous sommes tous concernés bien sur wii
sur des retraités y en a quatre qui ne
sont pas du tout concerné premiers
éléments parce que leur retraite est
vraiment très basse il y en a quatre qui
sont concernés mais qui verront au bout
du compte c'est à dire sur les deux
prochaines années
compenser cette augmentation de la csg
par une diminution de leur taxe
d'habitation
ce sera le cas d'ailleurs pour tout
l'ensemble des habitants effectivement
ça usure spécifique pour les retraites
deux ans mais ça va venir compenser
effectivement la hausse de la csg
et puis il y a deux retraités qui
effectivement sur ces dix qui sont
directement concernés par un prélèvement
mais par un prélèvement qui vient je dis
très clairement qui vient soulager par
contre des actifs puisque nous avons une
suppression des cotisations à la fois
maladie et chômage pour l'ensemble des
actifs et ça va permettre notamment de
privilégier je le dis très clairement le
travail c'est à dire que notre ambition
c'est une ville vernissage
voilà que la personne au smic dès cette
année à la rate
300 euros de plus de salaire net c'est
un enjeu essentiel pourquoi seul enjeu
essentiel parce qu'aujourd'hui la
personne au smic
elle gagne à peine plus que les minima
sociaux et nous devons faire en sorte
que dans notre pays
le travail paye et que véritablement lié
une incitation au travail et à faire en
sorte que ceux qui gagnent peu gagne un
peu plus michel lagourgue est ce que
vous comprenez cette philosophie
politique qui consiste à dire bien
finalement on va privilégier les actifs
parce que ce sont eux aujourd'hui le
moteur de l'économie non non vous doutez
bien que je ne suis pas entièrement
d'accord avec vous la csg effectivement
a été mise en place par michel rocard
pour ne pas le nommer en 1991
ok on ne met pas en cause cette cg qui
existent aujourd'hui mais c'est cette
hausse est quand même très importante
d'un 1,7 point je dis bien 1,7 point
parce que tout le monde parlait de 1,7
pour cent vingt enfants on est empreint
de séjourner en points ce qui représente
25 % en augmentation de la csg et quant
à la compensation pour pour les actifs
ll est très minime moi j'ai un exemple
si vous voulez que qu'on en parle c'est
d'un employé du bâtiment public qui est
tout juste au smig qui a un 1500 de
salaire de base 1573 84 de salaire de
base l'impact est très minime pour lui
parce que bien sûr l'assurance chômage a
diminué il ne sera plus qu à 0,95 au
lieu de 2,4 mais la csg augmenter la csg
a augmenté et millions finir sur la sur
la taxe d'habitation la taxe
d'habitation faut pas croire que ça va
représenter 300 ou 400 euros pour chacun
loin de là loin de là moi par exemple je
n'ai pas fait encore la simulation mais
ce n'est pas du tout sûr j'ai la chance
d'avoir d'habiter dans une petite
commune où la taxe d'habitation n'est
pas très élevé mais j'avais bien oui non
ça n'est jamais assez vrai et vous et
votre épouse 400 euros mais à 2 à 2 là
aussi il ya eu défaut d'explications
parce qu'on a toujours dit ne sera
impacté que les gens qui auraient moins
de 1200 euros c'est 1
reproche que je fais là dessus c'est
faux on en prend en compte le foyer
fiscal ça alors aussi bien alors aussi
bien les médias que vous les politiques
ça a été très très très très peu
expliquée il ya beaucoup de retraités
qui s'en sont rendus compte là au mois
de janvier
alors je vous propose je vais vous
laisser répondre rémy rebeyrotte dans un
instant je vais vous proposer d'écouter
ces réactions recueillies le 15 mars
dernier en marge de la manifestation des
retraités quelques quelques exemples de
situations très concrètes de retraités
en bourgogne
moi j'ai travaillé 43 ans et bein 35
heures mais 42 eur donc on a cotisé en
fonction et maintenant qu'on est
racketter c'est la double peine pour les
retraités qui ont déjà donc une retraite
vous verrez c'est un demi salaire de ce
que vous gagnez aujourd'hui et quand
vous supporter l'augmentation du train
du gaz des pillages qu'on ait des appels
con mais là csg sur des retraites vous
comprendrez qu'il ya des gens qui sont
pas d'accord prenais mon exemple je
touche 900 euros de retraite base et
complémentaires et en augmenter la csg
c'est inadmissible on tout ça
inadmissible alors voilà rémy rebeyrotte
on parle des mots très durs on parle de
raquette on parle de double peine c'est
quand même pas n'importe quoi est ce que
vous comprenez les inquiétudes de ces
personnes qui sont à la retraite tension
je le comprends parfaitement
aujourd'hui je m'explique c'est une
réforme sur trois ans c'est à dire qu'il
y à la mesure effectivement qui est
prise aujourd'hui et il ya une première
compensation pour certains qui est
intervenue dès janvier je parlais des
actifs pour les retraités
il y aura les effets bien sûr de la taxe
d'habitation et après demain c'est un
effet qui arrivent plus tard bizarrement
bien problème en encaisse d'abord et
après brawn et c'est ce qu'on
connaissait ce problème de méthode qui
est liée simplement au fait que ces
différentes taxes celles qui sont
allégées et celles qui sont augmentés ne
le sont pas au même moment donc on le
savait nous savions parfaitement qu'il y
aurait neuf mois un peu délicat par
rapport à ça puisqu'il ya des effets
qu'ils prennent
j'allais dire date au mois de janvier et
qui ont compensé d'abord en janvier
ensuite en octobre sur trois années et
donc nous savons si vous voulez qu'il y
a un temps un peu difficile par rapport
à ça et c'est ce qu'ils vraiment les
retraités s'est regardé et c'est sûr que
nous avons les retraités les
fonctionnaires mans la compensation se
fait comme pour les salariés
par contre nous savons si vous voulez
qu'il y avait un temps un peu dédicacer
ses neuf mois un peu délicat
effectivement puisque la cg s'applique
dès janvier mais c'est le mécanisme même
de la csg par contre par exemple la taxe
d'habitation et dans certaines communes
croyez moi ça n'est pas rien qu'un
allègement de certaines habitations dans
de très nombreuses communes ça n'est pas
rien je peux vous parler savamment de la
mienne toutes celles qui ont eu des
charges de centralité pendant des années
rémy revient en attaque sont élevés eh
bien elle n'interviendrait fait qu'il
manque au moins vous savez vous l'avez
entendu cette compensation de la taxe
d'habitation elle est pour tout le monde
et ces personnes âgées qu'on a entendus
dans les rues de dijon
le 15 mars dernier 10 oui mais nous on
est un peu les parents pauvres
finalement on a la même compensation
tout le monde mais en plus on a on n'a
pas la compensation qui vient sur les
cotisations salariales puisqu'on n'est
pas salarié oui il n'y aura je le disais
que de retraités sur dix qui seront
directement impactés avec une perte
légère
enfin une perte c'est vrai de pouvoir
d'achat alors oui un sur dix sont les
retraités qui ont des retraites un peu
plus élevé c'est vrai et c'est un choix
qui a été difficile à faire mais je
rappelle génération jusqu'à présent
pendant nos commentaires la cg il n'y
avait aucune compensation et que
d'autres candidats proposait une hausse
de deux points de la tva
et là il n'y aurait eu aucune
compensation là nous sommes sur un
double mécanisme
c'est vrai à la fois de de paiement de
charges supplémentaires il faut le dire
parce que nous devons équilibrer les
régimes sociaux et nous sommes quand
même en train progressivement de
rééquilibrer les régimes sociaux comme
nous nous sommes attaqués d'ailleurs aux
déficits de l'état
on va pas laisser des situations à nos
enfants qu'ils soient absolument
ingérable donc c'est extrêmement
important mais nous le faisons en même
temps avec un mécanisme de
redistribution
je le dis pour faire en sorte que ceux
qui travaillent et notamment les
smicards puisse avoir au bout du compte
quasiment un mois de salaire en plus un
treizième mois pour les smicards en bout
de période et ça c'est un enjeu
important alors vous n'auriez pas de 13e
mois mais chez dargaud même et rémy
rebeyrotte dit ça concerne deux
retraités sur dix finalement tout ça
pour ça oui tout ça pour ça il ya une
autre conséquence de la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation je pense que vous
allez tous bien conscients les
collectivités territoriales n'auront
plus leur déjà qu'elles sont déjà bien
moins de moins en moins de dotations
donc c'est encore un impôt qui va qui va
dominer sur les petites communes enfin
les petites communes we sur certaines
communes
donc là aussi sans compensation alors on
nous promet oui compensation au centime
près ça va durer un an deux ans mais
après on aura beaucoup d'illusions
là-dessus la taxe d'habitation sera
entièrement compensée par de lourds sacs
le mécanisme n'est pas un mécanisme
d'allocations de compensation un
mécanisme un impôt qui va surgir nouvel
amant qui vaille un mécanisme de
dégrèvement de dégrèvement alors on
repense on est en train de travailler
pour repenser globalement la fiscalité
locale je pense que c'est une c'est une
bonne chose mais cela dit la taxe
d'habitation sera entièrement compensée
pour les communes à leur poste un
mécanisme comme je le disais de
dégrèvements et non pas d'allocation
compensatoires comme on en a vu et
rajoutons à cela que ça va ne pas peser
par ailleurs puisque l'état le prend sur
10 milliards d'économies qu'il fait par
ailleurs je voudrais également parlé de
la situation des couples parce que vous
avez raison ça n'a pas forcément été
bien compris alors que ça a été des
moments de la campagne mali s'agissait
bien pas très bien expliqué revenu
fiscal et donc du couple oui non pas du
revenu personnel et donc pour tenir
compte de cela le gouvernement a décidé
en 2019
parce que quand on touche à la fiscalité
c'est toujours un peu délicat faut dire
les choses
oui ça s'en vient d'assurer le retraité
d'un terrien jeudi temps d'antenne
furent pour cent mille retraités
effectivement vaille à venir il y aura
non c'est ce même soir j'allais dire
plus défavorable aux personnes en couple
qu'aux personnes quand ils sont selon
vous les cieux on voit bien qu'il ya un
déficit d'explication sans doute de
compréhension de pédagogie je vous
propose d'écouter le président de la
république emmanuel macron interpellé
par des retraités à tour c'était le 14
mars dernier voilà les explications du
président
donc oui mais je vais vous expliquer
notre vie mais vous avez travaillé tout
vous dit pourquoi
là pour avoir une retraite non si vous
regardez le système français tel qu'on
l'a vous avez travaillé toute votre vie
pour payer la retraite de vos amis moi
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
personnes âgées et pour celles et ceux
qui savent mais je suis aussi obligé de
remettre en marche l'économie du pays et
donc la csg on l'a pas fait comme vous
dites non on l'a fait je l'expliqué de
la campagne on a baissé de trois points
toutes les cotisations salariales
donc tous ceux qui travaillent touchent
plus pour que liden plus par le travail
que ça redémarre plus vite pour qu'ils
puissent vous vous payer les retraites
alors on l'a entendu il ya des fois une
incompréhension y compris d'ailleurs
chez les actifs mais chez les retraités
c'est vrai aussi
le président de la république michel
dagbert rappelle qu on ne cotise pas
pour sa propre retraite mais pour celle
de ceux qui sont déjà mis à l'abri mais
ça vaut le coup d'être rappelé quand
même parce qu'on sent qu'il ya un petit
flottement là dessus un tout le monde
comprend bien comme ça marc mais bon il
faut qu'on arrête aussi que de dire
qu'on est des nantis des privilégiés
on va y venir non mais on l'entend
presque pratiquement à longueur de
journée j'étais la manifestation du 15
mars à paris à côté de moi il y avait
une grand-mère excusez-moi de l'appeler
comme ça c'est pas péjoratif 81,3
affectueux oui c'est infectueuses 1300
euros
donc elle se plaignait pas trop de sa
retraite un impact de 17 euros par mois
elle dit c'est la première fois que je
viens manifester c'est pas possible à la
600 euros de loyer donc il lui reste
environ 700 euros pour les charges et
tout pour sa nourriture et alice la
première fois de ma vie que je viens
dans une manifestation comme ça à 83 ans
nous avons a déclaré raymond vergès je
vais dire que les retraités sont des
noms on va y venir les spectateurs les
chasse cueillette de wilairot m qui
pense pas qu'on dit par contre la csg je
veux rappeler j'ai rappelé le mécanisme
oui il mis en place non mais pas son
geste est quand j'étais jeune actif
j'étais contente ce mécanisme est en
place pourquoi parce qu'à l'époque
j'aurais dû contribuer comme actif très
fortement à l'art équilibration à l'euro
parko réquilibrage qui les moyens du du
système bon donc c'était plutôt j'allais
dire pour les actifs une bonne chose on
aujourd'hui les actifs de 91 sont en
partie devenue il faut bien le dire les
retraités les retraités de 91 ne se sont
pas plaints il avait des raisons de se
plaindre lorsque tout à coup il était
mis à contribution alors que jusqu'ici
n'était pas on va y venir c'est un jeu
de solidarité jeudi sur la méthode parce
qu'on était sur les messageries travail
oui le président de la république disait
encore il ya quelques jours je ne sens
pas la colère monte dans le pays est ce
que vous vous aide de cet avis et où
est-ce qu'au contraire il ya une
inquiétude à avoir
et pourquoi cette inquiétude est ce que
ce sont les mesures en elle même ou
est-ce que c'est aussi la méthode c'est
à dire un manque finalement
d'explication et de pédagogie on voit
bien que vous réexpliquer évidemment et
on a l'impression que ça n'ait pas
compris ou non j'ai sentiment ciblé que
à la fois le gouvernement le président
lui-même vous l'avez montré expliqué
explique mais c'est vrai que ce sont des
mécanismes qui sont un peu complexe est
une réforme un peu complexe parce
qu'elle mixte à la fois le rééquilibrage
des comptes sociaux et en même temps
elle vit vraiment à rééquilibrer en
quelque sorte entre les catégories
sociales et à faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une solidarité qui s'exprime c'est une
mesure inscription vous vous la sentez
monter cette colère c'est une mesure
j'ai dès dire compliqué oui je la sens
monter essentiellement chez les deux
retraités sur dix dont je parle est qui
qui me disent je suis mis à contribution
de manière nette c'est désagréable
bon je leur fais remarquer que ce sont
des personnes je ne dis pas qu'ils sont
anti parce qu'ils ont travaillé ils ont
cotisé pour la retraite de leur est
nettement c'est pas une question de
vantis mans et un grenat qui disait
génération dorée ils ont est-ce que je
ne reprends pas ce terme là je dis
simplement si vous voulez bon ce sont
des personnes qui ont un revenu fiscal
mensuel supérieur à à 4000 euros je ne
dis pas qu'ils sont riches ou nantis je
dis qu'on les met effectivement un peu
un peu à contribution avec ce souci et
il le partage quand on leur dit quand on
leur dit mais c'est pour faire en sorte
que la personne qui est au smic gagnent
plus que des minima sociaux et ils
disaient vous effectivement vous avez
raison on a aujourd'hui ce phénomène des
travailleurs pauvres
moi j'ai des personnes dans ma
permanence qui viennent me voir en
disant
mais au fond est-ce que j'ai intérêt à
reprendre du travail parce que des
minima sociaux sont quasiment au même
niveau que le travail que je vais
prendre
bon il faut qu'à un moment on revalorise
le travail en en détournant je peux vous
dire que beaucoup de nos aînés beaucoup
des retraités ceux qui sont dans cette
situation là le comprennent
on attendait tout à l'heure des
retraités dire nous on a travaillé toute
notre vie on a payé nos cotisations et
maintenant on peut pas profiter du fruit
de notre retraite
non ils peuvent profiter eux mêmes mais
moins que ce qui était prévu
heureusement un peu moins pour certains
pour les deux dont je parlais que ce qui
était prévu mais pourront profiter du
fruit de leur retraite
j'allais je dois dire je dois dire que
par rapport à cette logique
si vous voulez on a une situation
aujourd'hui qui pour beaucoup de
retraités une situation un peu plus
confortable que n'étaient les retraites
de 1991 aucun n'était les retraites mais
ils se sont payé vous avez raison il ya
des retraites plus importante
oui ils se sont payés sur les retraites
complémentaires des retraites plus
importantes sur la retraite principale
ils ont contribué effectivement pour
leurs aînés c'est un système par
répartition cette grogne vient quand
même de deux photos quand même important
de ceux de la cg bien sûr elle a été
instituée ailier est lié on n'est pas
contre on veut pas on demande pas la
suppression mais c'est ce taux quand
même important qui fait mal nous les
retraités on est quand même on participe
solidaire on en paye la casa je pense
que je vous apprends rien la cotisation
additionnelle sérialité pour l'autonomie
d'ailleurs qu'on ne sait même pas alors
je vous le conçois c'est pas vous qui
l'avez mise en place mais on sait même
pas d'ailleurs où elle va ces clubs ont
donc on participe déjà avec ça
maintenant avec la csg est toujours sans
aucune échelle on a l'impression que le
président marc on y met il oppose les
actifs aux autres il veut c'est ça qui
nous permet mais la théorie du
gouvernement s'est aussi que les
retraités ont un pouvoir d'achat qui
augmenté plus vite que les actifs est ce
que vous comprenez qu'on vous demande du
coup de participer un peu plus à cet
effort national est la dernière
revalorisation pour nous les
les retraités date d'octobre 2010 7 0 8%
ce qui représente quatre fois rien et
celle de auparavant de 2014 0,1 pour
cent ce n'est pas vous c'est précédent
gouvernement effectivement 0 et 1%
on l'a comparé à une baguette de pain
par mois pour que vous voyez donc on n'a
pas été revalorisé depuis 2004 rémy
rebeyrotte ya aussi les retraités qui
disent nous on a un peu de pouvoir
d'achat c'est vrai mais on fait
travailler l'économie
la situation est difficile pour les
actifs mais on la prend à notre charge
puisque on aime nos enfants on aime nos
petits-enfants et si on nous ponctionne
on pourra plus qu'est ce que vous leur
dites alors je répète je redis que donc
sur des retraités 8 soit ne sont pas
ceux concernés par la mesure de la
hausse de la csg soit seront compensés
sur les trois années je le répète c'est
avec la taxe d'habitation leur faisons
l'agression qu'on leur retire des
méthodes et la taxe d'habitation ce
n'est pas cette impression s'est excusé
moi c'est la réalité
peut-être grande et des toutes petites
communes mais qui ont bénéficié des
services des plus grandes mais pour
beaucoup de retraités la taxe
d'habitation ça n'est pas rien
aujourd'hui et donc sur les deux ans ils
seront compensés reste effectivement la
situation de 2,2 des retraités sur dix
qui auront à contribuer un peu je le
disais par rapport à des retraites qui
sont évidemment les retraites les plus
élevés alors en termes de pouvoir
d'achat
vous avez raison mais nous allons
augmenter justement le pouvoir d'achat
des personnes au smic des bas salaires
et ça aussi c'est extrêmement important
je serais même tenté de dire que parmi
ceux qui consomment le plus c'est plutôt
les bas salaires à proportion de leurs
revenus et que les retraités les plus
aisés ont tendance plus tôt à épargner
mais ça se comprend parce que quand vous
avez une retraite un peu plus élevé ça
n'est pas forcément shôjo épargne un peu
plus vous proposez messieurs avant de
continuer se débarrasse qu'on arrive
bientôt au terme de cette émission
de suivre un couple de retraités daniel
et georges nivat talent près de dijon
christophe taris et rodolphe ogier les
ont rencontrés comme ça non quand il
pourra voir que les retraités se
contente de peu les pissenlits auront un
petit goût amer ce soir pour daniele
georges avec la hausse de la csg ce
couple de retraités perd plus de 60
euros par mois de revenu lui étaient
employés l infirmière et ce qui a du mal
à passer c'est qu'à côté de cette baisse
de revenus leurs autres dépenses sont en
hausse
tout augmente et on ne voit pas nous
retraités parce que je ne suis pas le
seul dans cette situation là nous
pensions n'augmentent pas et cette année
donc elle diminue parce que nous fait
une ponction supplémentaire
les asperges tiens c'est la saison des
asperges
je peux plus payer des asperges parce
que ça devient trop cher je fais des
comptes de plus en plus réduit de plus
en plus resserré
si je vais au cinéma je n'oublie pas de
dire que je suis senior alors que il ya
dix ans je m'en foutais des pissenlits
jusqu'au pain sec
daniel et n'a pas aimé que le président
lui demande des efforts pour aider les
jeunes car cet argent en moins c'est
justement aussi pour ses enfants est
bonne je les aide
et alors quand on va me prendre de
l'argent la fin on va me faire manger du
pain sec
eux je leur donne rien j'pourrais plus
les aider comprenez c'est même pas une
histoire personnelle parce qu'on est
extrêmement nombreux à avoir ce genre de
situation si c'est pas les enfants sont
les petits enfants qu'on aide
on fait ce qu'on peut ni privilégier ni
assisté daniel et george sont bien
décidés à ne pas lâcher le morceau
alors rémy rebeyrotte michel dago mais
le disait aussi tout à l'heure on voit
aussi dans cet exemple on a l'impression
par moments que le gouvernement oppose
retraité actif est ce que ça n'est pas
dangereux d'opposer les français les uns
aux autres et est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
essayer de rassembler tout ça parce que
tout le monde a son utilité dans cette
société j'imagine que vous êtes d'accord
vous avez raison d'ailleurs la cg
concerne aussi bien les uns que les
autres les uns et les autres seront
compensés pour eux 8/10 comme je disais
pour 20% par contre des personnes il y
aurait effectivement une légère perte de
pouvoir d'achat je le disais au profit
des actifs alors c'est j'allais dire un
complément à cette solidarité familiale
dont parlait cette dame c'est à dire que
il est extrêmement important
effectivement il puisse y avoir un
soutien à ceux qui sont attentifs ou à
ceux qui sont au chômage de la part de
leurs parents voire de leurs grands
parents
donc si vous voulez cette solidarité
elle s'exerce d'une manière à la fois
internes aux familles elle peut
s'exercer aussi entre les familles c'est
justement une partie de cette réforme
répond ça c'est vrai parce qu'on arrive
au terme de l'émission michel dago mais
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
gouvernement recule cette semaine
edouard philippe a décidé qu'il y aurait
100 mille personnes qui entraîne une
idée pour par rapport à ces difficultés
c'est à dire les cent mille foyers les
plus les moins aisés qui sont concernés
par ces formules cette annonce c'est
peut-être pour nous faire taire aussi
mais bon sang mille retraités sur 7
million et demi que l'on est pour moi
c'est rien ça non ça ne suffit pas et on
fait quand même partie de la de la vie
économique de notre pays
tout augmente notre pouvoir d'achat
malgré tout cela vous en convient on l'a
vu dans le reportage
oui je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
commentaire oui tout augmente
on subit les mêmes conséquences que nous
aussi que les actifs
les carburants ont augmenté le gaz
augmenter tout bon on subit les mêmes
conséquences
mais si ça continue comme celle à plus
de 7 kg au fait des voyages les
retraités aussi si on ne fait plus de
voyages y aura peut-être plus de
d'autocaristes ira peut-être moins de
moins de l'agent de voyages
donc à vous poser une question rapide
nous reste une minute en 10 secondes
est-ce que vous avez d'autres moyens
d'action est ce que vous allez retourner
dans la rue est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que vous pouvez pesé
écoutez moi j'ai une réunion de bureau
la semaine prochaine à paris on en
discute entre nous et puis bon on fait
partie de ce qu'on appelle un groupe des
le groupe des neuf ce neuf associations
de retraités donc à suivre
rémy rebeyrotte est ce que vous avez
peur pour la cote de popularité du
président de la république les retraités
sont aussi les gens qui votent oui il
nomme maintenant d'émettre
nous savions que les réformes que nous
avons affaire ne sont pas des réformes
facile j'en ai expliqué la logique pour
simplement terminer je voudrais dire que
pour nous il est extrêmement important
que la porte reste ouverte et qu'il y
ait un merci nous sommes dans les
discussions merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté de répondre à ces
questions en direct ce matin merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant l'actualité régionale puis la
partie nationale de dimanche en
politique francis letellier au soin
benoît hamon ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle bon dimanche